now to signs of significant progress for
two potential coronavirus vaccines this
is encouraging news moderna and
pfizer both started large-scale trials
yesterday
the first in the u.s out of more than
150 vaccines in development about two
dozen
are already being tested on humans meg
oliver is outside a modern testing
center in new jersey
meg we are all waiting and hoping for
good news here good morning to you
good morning gail a readout from
modernist phase 3 trial could come by
november so there is a chance a vaccine
could be ready by the end of the year
volunteers have started receiving either
the vaccine or placebo in this blind
study
that experts hope couldn't finally bring
this coronavirus pandemic
under control it seems quite possible
that we
may very well have results by november
or december
maybe possibly a little earlier national
institutes of health director dr
francis collins has high hopes for the
vaccine his agency developed with
moderna
and says 30 thousand volunteers are
being chosen based on their risk of
exposure
they'll be in areas where the virus is
still spreading
we will see whether any of them actually
get sick
dr hannah el saleh one of only three
moderna principal investigators
overseeing the 89 test sites says if the
vaccine can work in over
half the volunteers it would be a major
step to protecting the entire country
i've seen some modeling around what
level
of immunity is needed and the modeling
places it at somewhere between 50 and 60
percent
herd immunity pfizer's late stage trial
announced monday
will also include 30 thousand
participants in 39 u.s states
as well as brazil germany and argentina
both vaccines use a piece of rna genetic
code
which tells the cells in the body to
make a safe modified version of the
viral protein
that triggers an immune response to
fight the virus
tv anchor dawn baker from our savannah
georgia affiliate
got the very first dose of the moderna
vaccine monday
morning i got tired of just sitting here
worried that i can't do any more than
wear a mask and try to stay away from
people
it's good to know that i could be a part
of what could be
the ultimate solution but even if a
vaccine is approved and available
there's some question as to how many
would take it
a cbs news poll on monday showed only 30
percent of adults would get a vaccine as
soon as possible
50 percent would consider it or wait to
see what happens
and 20 percent said they'd never get one
cbs news medical contributor
dr david agus says the usual financial
and regulatory hurdles were pushed aside
when it came to the development of a
coveted vaccine
we've compressed it all into an amazing
time period
because we need it because there was no
choice this is a war on our soil
and we have to respond
top health officials including dr
anthony fauci stress
no measures are being cut in the
development of any of these vaccines
dr david agus says all safety protocols
are being followed except
one long-term studies and that's simply
because we need the vaccine
now anthony we sure do meg thank you
very much